for the middle portion of the schedule in the
Metropolitan Division c withal will deal this
off is pson solid defenseman fires that shot
deflex comes all the way through Chris leang
going up against one another very quickly Penguins
win the draw so they will go right to work Carlson
turns it to Crosby he fires that one takes off
and finds last and so gets it back to Carlson
and across to Crosby again Alex gensel side of
the net huling across and it's a slam dunk for
Rael and there is the difference in the Penguins
power play from when the Flyers saw them earlier
and they went 0 for eight against Philadelphia
they're on the board quickly and it's one- nothing
Pittsburgh dusting pucks off and you can see this
is a set play I mean they're they're getting it
down to malc and there's two options for malcon
there he can either spin around and get it on net
himself or he can try by the back door play to
Rael who's waiting for it and sanheim not able
to intercept that cross that's not the start the
Flyers wanted just 45 seconds in have to respond
here's tippet atson for the shot and it takes
off he gets set up again zamula to coni KI for
tip it was off the mark to go back for it he'll
get it back to Conti all the way through to fary
far out to Z he'll hammer it deflected and goes
up into the safety netting sanim and now l f it
back to sanheim at the hash mark from the angle
is shot right into the chest elovich he makes the
save and hangs on see if the Penguins can give him
some magic here tonight sanheim fires in the save
again and no further play Then Pittburgh begins it
second power play a quick shot save rebound Dan in
front but he couldn't L up now to C for the shot
save made the rebound out toward Crosby who's got
it the power play begins for the Penguins there
a series of chances for the Flyers when it was
four on four cier gets it to the net just hops
over ainson stick there and followup chance for
now it comes back across to Malin Malin in front
the tip oh hard a beautiful save heat some help
the Flyers finally clear the puck Out of the Blue
Carter Hart has made two huge saves to keep this
a one-goal game he'll settle things Crosby all
the way out right on the tape now back it comes
to Malin back across the tip and another save he
Deni CA didn't get all of it obviously there's a
lot going on with that cray but big hit there from
delore as he levels and Harkin now delore has the
puck he's going to get run over and knocked over
and lost the puck and Harkins takes the shot and
it went wide back out it goes Carson his shot into
heavy traffic they score not sure if it deflected
in front there were several Penguins there
but the Penguins now lead two nothing to the
net quickly and you can see the traffic that was
in front of Hart I mean he had no vision to that
puck that was a great look that last look of what
Hart did see or didn't see and all he saw was a
bunch of players in front of him he tries to look
over the traffic rust with support right back out
to leang his shot blocked by lton comes free to
rust fires really look hesitant right now comes
into the slot big save by puck sitting there is
jammed out of there by CA but right back to the
tank Malin who turns and fires another save by
Art who's given up two but he's also made about
four Dandy saves he has he has so far but back up
to wall f is there quickly to zamula right on the
line still on side zamula Waits deals it off tip
it the shot he scars oh and tip it a seed and a
power play goal as the Flyers within one Poise
by zamula at the blue line and it's what John
toell talked about he showed the Poise and the
willingness to make plays Under Pressure here
patience attack and then find the outlet and
that's tippet who's coming down that strong
side flank and for tippet he kind of gets lost
up by the blue line and that's why he's so open
and when that puck is on his stick we've talked
about his touch to the middle his pass not enough
on it now two forwards are caught bengu have a
four on two here's Carlson right up the middle
waiting holding Dilan to Malin Malin the shot
save heart rebound at the way could not get it
that led to the odd man for the Penguins and good
job here sanheim trying to take that back door got
it out to Center trying to get it further down
the ice oh now falling is sealer and so there's
room for gel for the shot save rebound spun
back out by Crosby to Carlson he'll wind in
Blast that's plucked penalty Killers got to be
getting a little tired here's lton trying for
that home run pass it bounce it to sealer it's
a two-on one he gets to Cony Cony moving up he
looks back to CER the shot he hits the post hit
the post the first period to feed from kkny and
almost I mean he beat n delovic just not able to
beat the PO and the Flyers acted quickly a team
that is playing very well they're going to get
a player that's going to help them for this year
as well two onone the other way off a turnover
here's rust with a shot big save by hard again
that one up near his shoulder Tang right back to
Pon is shot into traffic again and rist Lan will
get it to the line not out and now paling moves up
and he's got half away with him paling weights two
half the away got it shot off and that oich made
the save 21 Penguins Flyers that close to tying it
up the follows Conor all the way to the corner
the puck up the wall back out rule across for
Graves Graves flips it back to the middle it's
jabbed at but to rued it's shot score Chad rued
of all people ends up beating Hart and it's 3-1
Pittsburgh I don't think Hart saw this shot uh
he was slow reacting to it right underneath
and we'll get a good look at it from here if
there is traffic or not oh yeah tip it right
as the shot was in route he comes right into
the shot uh to the sight lines of of Hart and
maybe Hart was anticipating a potential block
but you can see just on that one there he's kind
of searching for it surveying yeah a lot of these
young players are piling up points but he does a
lot of things he a turn over by the Flyers heart
the save can't find the rebound still reaching
for it now he's got it and here good job by
arkins to create that turnover and like a hot
potato there by the top of the crease and many
times you can't freeze it quickly it allows for
the opposition to get in there and start hacking
and whacking and that's when Steeler swats it
around behind but it makes it way all the way
through to Carlson who was nearly stripped and
now they move it ahead and here's o Conor over
comes St he couldn't get it o Conor shot save
rebound another save har got him twice it's
you might have one Carter not once not twice but
eventually three times only got the two but trust
me there was a third great stuff by Hart as he
keeps this a 3-1 game he's played well in this
game 25 saves Ires win the draw s keeps it in
swoops in moves in shoots save rebound course
they're headed in his skates good Joseph loses
his helmet he has to go to the bench chal Lan
trying to get an icing call here but OK Conor
canel that one here's zamula he tried to lead
tippet tippet wasn't aware of the pass coming
here's OK Conor Conor turns with it got it to
Mal he scores that's how quickly they can make
you pay if Genny Malin Beating Heart it's 4-1
Pittsburgh well the penguins have found ways
to get to scoring areas and just not a clean
exit by the Flyers a turnover and it seems
like a harmless play two guys go to one and
that leaves malcin open so you make one
mistake and then you compound it and that
leaves a real talented player and malcin
in an area where he's dangerous right at
the dot and that left-handed stick sees the
far side of the net but delich had a shaky
moment in Boston too this one comes to an
end P's battling but can't do much there in
round three of hockey's Battle of Pennsylvania
goes convincingly in the favor of the penguin